[Music]
you want a podcast
i got a smart cat you want a podcast i
got a smart cat
you want a podcast i got a smart cat you
wanna you wanna if you wanna
you wanna you wanna do you wanna podcast
do you wanna show
do you get your labs from computer radio
with this bro scotty mo
it's about time to include your [ __ ]
everybody's pockets flip for that legend
kevin smith
[Music]
welcome to this podcast i'm kevin smith
okay kids this is a good one today man
um when you're an artist uh
you get fed like everyone else by
other artists um you know
if you like entertainment if you like
making movies tv
singing uh [ __ ] writing
you know it oh my god it's a big ass bee
in here um it
it's very rare that you do it isolated
you know i'm sure there are some
geniuses out there that literally just
like i [ __ ]
have no influences whatsoever but uh you
know
i came into my owner something a lot of
us
do what we do because we see other
people do what they do and their work
feeds our work um case in point chasing
amy
there's a scene uh with the jay and
salam bob
at the diner and um you know they're
they're uh having a conversation with
our main character holden mcneil
who is going through some girl problems
with his girlfriend alyssa jones
and at one point uh jay utters uh the
immortal line
it's like cube says life ain't nothing
but
[ __ ] and money um
that and and in jay and silent bob
strike back
while the jay and solomon bob are hiding
out
uh in the diner when uh
marshall willen holly comes looking for
them
right before they know that the cops are
outside
jay breaks into a bit of [ __ ] the police
by
nwa [ __ ] the police [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] the police yo yo [ __ ] the
police
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the police yo [ __ ] up so
the guy i get to talk to today
informed what it is i do i mean it
sounds
weird to say but he's in the dna
of my characters now and
borrowing from him and lending that
credibility
to my characters has made them
a strong kind of fabric within the world
of pop culture and it's given me a
borrowed
credibility where people like oh he
[ __ ]
he knows the work of nwa nice cubans
going back to you know of course the 90s
now everybody does
but um i never got a chance
to thank him i will never forget sitting
there writing that script
and wanting jay to say something cool
and i was like
i know exactly what that will be it'll
be it was because
jason was a hardcore hardcore
uh nwa fan so it wound up
in my work man and today i get to talk
to a guy
who's responsible uh for that um
we're going to talk about many things
but chiefly we're going to talk about
weed
because like me he entered into the weed
space
and like me he entered into the weed
space with the same company with caviar
gold caviar mike who makes our
snoogins and snoozy boochies and
berserker
he came up with his own joint called
good day
and it's tasty and it [ __ ] smokes
fine and [ __ ]
all caviar weed does welcome to smodcast
the smile
there's more honor than i feel my house
could bear
the great ice cube how are you sir yeah
yeah
what's up kevin how you feeling man oh
incredible you know
above ground for heaven's sakes and
smoking so that's a good matter
[ __ ] at the end of the day yes now we
were gonna speak earlier
but uh cube was like i'm gonna go see my
pops
um and which endeared you even more to
me you know
a man who realizes the value of his
of his parents um you know that's
that's everything um a lot of people
uh of course have seen uh the movie
um about your portion of your life and
stuff
yeah my question though is kind of
related to that
when you're a young artist um and
particularly in the case of you guys
you know you're definitely not adhering
to
the norms of like well i i you know i do
this
i do this i do everything right i abide
by what my parents say
did you have a tight relationship with
your
parents when you started breaking yeah
you know i've always had a good
relationship with my parents
um you know i always appreciated my
pops for for staying and sticking there
and being there for me you know a lot of
a lot of dudes uh fathers you know
felt it easier to oh you know they
couldn't
for whatever reason stay in a
relationship
but my father stayed there he was a big
influence so
you know it was always love and
positivity you know
when it came to me and my family um
when i started doing music um they was
happy for me you know they was
they was happy that it was something
positive um
you know i began playing football and
[ __ ]
so it was happy anything that was
keeping me out the streets
so when i started doing music
you know the music is hardcore [ __ ] so
my mom's was like you know her church
her church friends and [ __ ] was was
showing her the kind of records i was
doing
right so uh
she you know she asked me you know why
you gotta
why you gotta be the one to do all the
cussing on the record you know why you
can't
make clean wraps i said
i said i got some clean raps but
i said don't nobody want to hear that
you know i mean they want to hear they
want to hear what's real
right and she would be on me about those
records you know i'm saying until
i showed her you know little money i was
making that
time and
then you know i was bringing home gold
records and
hanging them up in her house and things
like that
so they was just straight crying you
know like
i'm not in the streets i ain't tripping
but i am
um you know doing something that's
getting recognition and positivity and
putting plaques on her wall and giving
her a little change
and so the church ladies
seem to shut the hell up after this
it was a positive thing you know what i
mean
i had a little bit of that when i made
uh clerks my mom was like
you know the first her review of the
movie to me was you spent
27 000 on this piece of garbage and i
was like thanks mom very carol brady of
you
the moment my mom was interviewed by
entertainment tonight
at like the clueless premiere you've
never
seen someone more proud she's like well
i could do without the language her big
thing because she was also very very
churchy
her big thing was like everybody's going
to think that i taught you this language
you know i was like that'll make that'll
make you look cool
amongst my friends mom um
what was it like and what does it
continue to be like but
going back to when you guys broke what
was it like to be the voice
of a generation
um well i mean it's
it's incredible to be heard it's
incredible
you know i never looked at us as the
voice of a generation i looked at us
as doing what we do
um what's the trip is
we had uh we had just kind of
you know swallowed the fact that we was
just gonna be neighborhood hood
stars we was to be hood stars we wasn't
going to be
you know run dmc we wasn't going to be
uh epmd and you know just the big groups
so as soon as we kind of you know kind
of just kind of like
sunk in let that sink in and and just
absorb that
that's when everything blew up and it
just started taking off
so um always was
proud that i was on the same stage with
ll cool jack i was on the same stage
with slick rick
public enemy um that
that to me was the accomplishment i
never looked at it like oh damn we the
voice of a generation
i always feel like we we doing what we
supposed to do we showing the world what
the west coast is all about
you know along with ice tea um
you know but it was other groups it was
king t it was compton's most wanted
um it was a few other groups uh dj quick
you know so we were just to me
like spearheading the movement um going
behind what iced tea
had you know iced tea had laid
you know some some foundation for us
that we can kind of slide in on so
you know i just felt like we was doing
our part you know i mean uh
it's not until afterwards and i look
back and then
see that yeah we were speaking for a lot
of people who couldn't
or or just wasn't going to come from
this angle
was the was were they
the the way in for you was ice tea the
way in
because like you and i are roughly the
same age and and i'm 50 or
50s right same thing um
when and i was uh of course nowhere near
the west coast and growing up in the
[ __ ] suburbs in new jersey but i was
a massive
rap fan so the we must have been into
like roughly the same things around the
same time i remember when public enemy
first broke prior to that of course like
it was just
all run dmc for me they were they were
the the top
but then there was bands like
stetsosonic audio too
did you listen to them as well yeah you
know i've been on tour with them too
as well you know so it's cool um
yeah we was we was fans of all the east
coast groups like they were
they were pros to us and we were
like locals we considered ourselves
locals you know we weren't known
um nationwide worldwide so
you know those were what we were
aspiring to be
um but iced tea did kick the door in he
he worked with a lot of groups in new
york he was friends with
you know keras one zulu nation
um him in africa islam
um which i think africa islam is from
new jersey
uh so you know or new york i don't want
to get it wrong and [ __ ] i don't know
michael from one of those boroughs but
but at the end of the
day ice tea was he was going on a
dope jam tour so he was actually
touring and and taking west coast hip
hop
nationwide and kind of you know
softening the
the the uh the people love
for the for nwa you know i think
without iced tea um nwa
would have would have took a little
longer to break
yeah for sure i remember when uh his was
the first
taste of like west coast rap that i'd
had
and i remember when that i was a
cassette guy um so i remember when that
i was a tape guy i remember when that
set came out
and bought it and listened to it and his
his that his lyrics were
they had taken it up a notch um boogie
down productions
krs1 skylark they were the first
like like rappers that i remember were
very specific about
like my nine and and guns and stuff yeah
up until that point it was just you know
it was that everyone throw your hands in
there waving like you just don't care or
i mean crazy would play easy he would
play criminal minded
all day long i'm gonna embarrass myself
by
by uh doing uh boogie down productions
we'll always get paid to take the
whacking songs
god he was i think my first favorite
lyricist krs-1
because it was so based in language
everything was like
rich language like don't get me wrong i
love run dmc but
you know being chris rock would always
like chris rock's also a big run dmc fan
so when we started working together like
run dfc was something we bonded over
and you know chris i think was the first
one to be like look they're amazing but
let's be honest
like you know um he's like the next
thing you know you'll have a big car
is not the most winning lyric in rap
history is
he goes does the job for at the time but
he's like you know
lyrics got much better after that um krs
one's lyrics
just like changed my world in terms of
like what's that
the game yeah did it really yeah
i mean he showed that you you
uh one mc can have a hundred styles
you know it wasn't about you know
finding your cadence and just rocking
your style
and that sleep that's it he showed that
you can have
many different styles you know and
and so it it opened it up it opened
up uh your imaginations
of how many different cadences you can
master
you know and and still rhyming on time
and
you know so keras one was a big
influence you know
um you know it's like
uh i just think you know
up until [ __ ] probably
[Music]
man i don't know when carries one wasn't
an influence you know what i'm saying i
mean you even talked about
you know the blueprint album you know
what i'm saying
i mean the day begins with a grin and a
prayer
excuse my sins yes crazy
crazy work and i've seen him
rock a show you know carrots we won like
i seen him standing at the front of a
stage like a real mc
and just rock the crowd and
that's always been impressive to me you
know i mean he's a he's a real um
when first time you got to share a stage
with somebody who was you were a big fan
of
you you you know somebody i can't
believe we're here what who was it
man it was a heavy-duty boys it was salt
and pepper
utfo yeah we had a show with him in san
diego
guess who else was on that show who is
the hammer
and uh too short first time we met
too short nancy hammer get out of here
yeah uh down to san diego and um
you know we have been doing local shows
in l.a and here
you know this tour was going through san
diego uh
utfo tour was born through san diego
and it had uh salt and pepper on the
show
heavy duty and the boys and uh
and then we you know we was opening up
too so wait you guys
you guys opened for them yeah we opened
for them
and did you open with the first album
i don't even think we had the first
album out we just had
dope ass singles out you know like right
easy had i think easy album was out easy
does it was probably out but
but we had like dope man now gangster
gangsta a ball
so we had singles that were
you know enough for us to do 25 minutes
30 minutes show
what a was it a tone shift for that
audience from you guys to then like now
salt and pepper every day in the boys
hell yeah
oh yeah i was on there too with his
little dirty mouth so
between us and too short i think we
balanced everything out
but uh i know the east coast groups was
really performing on us you know um
they was just you know i remember heavy
duties just saying damn man
y'all get away with that how y'all get
away with that
and uh you know we didn't know no better
we was like man this
this that's what got us on the [ __ ]
road if we were still doing
you know regular raps and [ __ ] we
probably wouldn't be here so
we're gonna stick with it did you um
did when did did when you guys were like
we're gonna push the line we're gonna
this is what we're gonna rap about
um clearly it's gonna upset some people
is there any fear behind it or you're
just like no or was there ever a moment
where you're like maybe we shouldn't
go as far as we do no no that ain't no
fear behind it because we had already
started it we were doing mixtapes
just for the swap meet out here uh
rhodium swap meet um
so we was just
doing hardcore cussing and [ __ ] on the
mixtapes because we felt like it wasn't
going on the radio
right and we could talk about the
neighborhood because we wasn't trying to
sell records in you know philly you know
what i'm saying
we just talking about the neighborhood
so let's keep it about the [ __ ] that's
going on around here
um so those got popular
those got real popular as a matter of
fact
easy had a tape
when he reconnected with dre him and dre
knew each other in high school but they
reconnected
once easy start hearing these tapes on
the street like who's doing this
it's dr dre and they pretty probably
know who i was at the time
so um you start coming around you know
this is like
84 85 you start coming around this
and um he wanted to be a manager he
wanted to get out the dope game
and so he
he wanted to manage his group it was his
group out in new york he thought
i'm in la but i know these kids from new
york
i need to work with them so we can
actually be famous and [ __ ] you know i
mean
so there wasn't no real
like big la rappers at the time you know
what i'm saying just
i mean iced tea was on his way but
everybody was still
finding our way so
um i wrote a song for them um and they
turned the [ __ ] down you said in the
movie called boys in
the hood yeah you know drake convinced
easy to do it and
rest is history but so we was like
you know easy let us do those kind of
records where
you know we switches dude named lonzo
who was he was a cool dude but
he was more into slacks and horror shoes
and
you know he was into the barcades and
[ __ ]
you know confunction and these bands
these funk bands and [ __ ] and he wasn't
really in the rap you know the first
thing he said was like
who the [ __ ] want to hear about somebody
going to jail you know what i mean
that's what he just found this [ __ ] i
don't want to hear nobody rapping about
going to [ __ ] jail
and he's like this will never catch on
you know what i'm saying
it's so funny
it's so funny to think about now that
somebody was like you get like lyrics
that people
could relate to uh why do you think that
would work
like there was a whole audience not
being spoken to who could then
hear their lives reflected in in your
work that's
that's groundbreaking um yeah it was it
was good [ __ ]
at the end of the day i mean we didn't
think we was going to go too
far because there was so much cussing on
it
so we felt like our records was going to
be
they used to put eddie murphy richards
prior
uh red fox records in these sections
called the blue
section and we thought our record's
going to be with the dolomite records
and [ __ ]
like that blue section we didn't think
it'd
ever make it to the regular you know
front of the store or rack
and um [ __ ] it did
yes fast um what when did
you mention boys in the hood before when
did
acting come into it because did you act
in high school or anything or no
no no i never even thought about acting
um who
was it john singleton who approached you
or what
john singleton is the first one to come
at me about it
he said look man i got a movie you
you'll be perfect for
and i said where's your movie called you
said boys in the hood i said hey man
that's fun
what you talking about yeah my lawyer
will be contacting you
he said he said no i was inspired by
what y'all did but it's a story about
the neighborhood i wouldn't have
listened to him you know i was just
at the time trying to be the greatest
rapper in the world
and that was like laser focus so
he pursued me for about two years and
finally you know he a script came to my
my manager and i had forgot about
john i forgot all about him until i
walked in and saw him
sitting there and like just got
something to do with you he said yeah
remember me
like yeah i remember you man and then
you know he just helped me become an
actor you know straight up he helped me
you know
through the process between him cuba
good and junior
lawrence fishburne you know they really
helped me
stay on my feet and not you know
[ __ ] fall flat on my face you know
what i'm saying
um like it reminds me of
uh like i put j and stuff cause i'm like
oh my god like i'm gonna write a part
around this person
um it sounds like john did the same
thing
in your case did you find like did you
have to
act or was it close to your persona
well i mean it was close to my persona
but to be honest i could have played all
any three of those characters
right yeah especially with the footballs
yeah i grew up with these dudes
you know what i'm saying there's like
dudes from my neighborhood
clearly like so um
you know i could have did any part so it
was uh
it was great man you know just to have a
movie
i remember reading the script and uh
and i had my wife read it
and after she finished reading this you
know we was both blown away
and only got ten percent
[Music]
i was like damn how we grew up is worth
the movie is movie worthy
there's a guy who was singing about how
they grew up like
yeah and i didn't i thought you know i
thought we could make
raps about this [ __ ] but like a movie
uh so you know i mean that was kind of
cool
the um i remember when that movie came
out
like of course john's story as
the film filmmaker who came from film
school
like you know who said to an agent like
all the movies you guys make are
[ __ ] you need to make something real
and
you like put his money where his mouth
was and and wound up making
uh boys in the hood so naturally you
know that was one of those stories that
as a young filmmaker
you're like yeah yeah everything's
possible anything's possible but that
movie was
massive tapped into the zeitgeist was
talked about everywhere
and it's also a really wonderful and
watchable movie
um like at that point
what was because you worked with john
later on in higher learning and
and probably other things right how many
times you worked with john
i i just worked on hiring learning just
those two
yeah we were supposed to do part of
justice
i was supposed to do poetic justice
but i'm glad tupac took that role
um you know i just didn't feel
right about the role so i'm glad tupac
took it
did you really like there was a moment
where he was presented to you and you
were like
yeah he wrote it for me really wrote it
for me yeah
yeah and um we just couldn't agree on a
certain part of the script
um i just didn't like the fact that
uh you know don't get me wrong janet
jackson is fine as hell
but i wouldn't throw out my homeboy for
on the side of the road before we got to
oakley he did
you know we did get into it so
i just felt like i don't want to play a
character that kicks his homeboy out
for a girl he just met he referred me
and
he didn't want to change the part so i
said give it to pop
what uh what was he like because you
work to them as uh
as the young director the guy who kind
of broke on the scene
was was there confidence commanding
really he was always commanding
yeah he was always commanded man you
know he uh
it was a trip just to see him take
control over the set
you know what i'm saying it was just a
trip to see him take control
because was he his age yeah
you know i seen you know i had done i
have been on video shoots
but you know to see somebody that young
this is my first film set
so you know i'm thinking
you know there's people there older than
him i know they've been in the business
longer than him
and but he was the man
and and uh i appreciated
watching him do that you know i learned
a lot from him
when it was time for me to do my movies
um to to know what you want
um and fight for what you want
um and you know
don't let too many people
you know it's like it can't be a
director by committee you can listen to
everybody
but at the end of the day you got to be
the one directing that [ __ ] or you know
or let the director do a step
sweating all the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
you